liebe Mitbürgerinnen und liebe
Mitbürger wenn ich im Land unterwegs bin
sagen mir gerade auch viele ältere so
geballt so Schlag auf Schlag habe ich
das alles noch niemals
erlebt kaum war Corona halbwegs vorbei
brach Russland mitten in Europa einen
unerbittlichen Krieg vom Zaun kurz
darauf dreht uns der russische Präsident
den gassahn ab und im Herbst gab es auch
noch den brutalen Terrorangriff der
Hamas auf
Israel so viel Leid so viel Blut
vergießen unsere Welt ist unruhiger und
rauer geworden sie verändert sich in
gerade zuu atemberaubender
Geschwindigkeit auch wir müssen uns
deshalb verändern vielen von uns
bereitet das sorgen bei einigen sorgt
das auch für Unzufriedenheit ich nehme
mir das zu Herzen und zugleich weiß ich
wir in Deutschland kommen dadurch
erinnern Sie sich wo wir vor einem Jahr
standen 3 4 5% Wirtschaftseinbruch
hatten und viele Expertinnen und
Experten vorausgesagt viele befürchteten
die Preise würden immer weiter steigen
es gab die Sorge vor Stromausfällen und
kalten Wohnung es ist anders gekommen
die Inflation ist gesunken Löhne und
Renten steigen die Gasspeicher sind für
diesen Winter
randvoll es ist anders gekommen weil wir
uns gegen den Wirtschaftseinbruch
gestemmt haben weil wir Energie gespart
und rechtzeitig vorgesorgt haben wir
alle gemeinsam
wir kommen auch mit Gegenwind
zurecht das macht die Herausforderung
unserer Zeit nicht kleiner aber das gibt
Mut dass wir ihnen gewachsen sind wer
wenn nicht ihr in Deutschland kriegt das
hin das sagen mir viele um uns herum in
Europa und auf der Welt und da ist etwas
dran noch nie hatten so viele Frauen und
Männer in Deutschland eine Arbeitsstelle
wie heute das sichert unseren Wohlstand
das gibt uns die Möglichkeit kraftvoll
in die Zukunft zu investieren und das
müssen wir auch denn wer in diesen Tagen
mit der Bahn unterwegs ist oder vor
einer maroden Brücke im Stau steht der
merkt unser Land wurde zu lange auf
Verschleiß gefahren deshalb investieren
wir jetzt in ordentliche Straßen und
eine bessere Bahn in eine saubere
Energieversorgung und in besseren
Klimaschutz in gute Arbeitsplätze und
zwar in Wirtschaftszweigen in denen
Deutschland schon immer Weltspitze war
genauso wie in Branchen wo wir
Nachholbedarf haben z.B bei der
Herstellung von Computerchips oder
Batterien all das ist woh dem
Hintergrund des weitreichenden Urteils
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts von Mitte
November nicht einfacher geworden nicht
alle Vorhaben die wir in den Blick
genommen hatten werden wir umsetzen
können aber war es zugleich wir
investieren auch im kommenden Jahr eine
Rekordsumme in unsere Zukunft und unterm
Strich entlasten wir auch weiterhin all
diejenigen die jeden Tag aufstehen und
zur Arbeit gehen die unser Land am
Laufen halten von morgen Anzahlen
Arbeitnehmerin und Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland 15 Milliarden Euro weniger
an Steuern eine vierköpfige Familie mit
einem normalen Einkommen hat dadurch im
nächsten Jahr mehr als 500 € zusätzlich
zur Verfügung zusammen mit der
Steuersenkung in diesem Jahr macht das
über 1600 € mehr dazu kommen das höhere
Kindergeld das Wohngeld und nicht
zuletzt die Senkung der Beiträge zur
Sozialversicherung für all diejenigen
die wenig verdienen die Pakete ausfahren
oder Supermarktregale einräumen die
vorhere Kinder zur Schule bringen und
noch nach der Arbeit den Haushalt
schmeißen
über sie liest man nicht jeden Tag in
der Zeitung aber mir ist es wichtig dass
Ihre Leistung gesehen und anerkannt wird
Liebe Mitbürgerin und Mitbürger auch in
Zeiten wie diesen gibt es Dinge auf die
wir uns verlassen können die uns stark
machen wir haben Freunde in Europa und
rund um den Globus Partner mit denen ich
mich Tag für Tag darüber abstimme wie
wir unsere Sicherheit in Deutschland und
Europa
gewährleisten stark macht uns die
Europäische Union wenn die EU
geschlossen auftritt dann handelt sie
für mehr als 400 Millionen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in einer Welt mit acht
künftig sogar 10 Milliarden Menschen ist
das ein echtes
Pfund darum ist es so wichtig dass
Europa geeint und gestärkt aus der
Europawahl im kommenden Jahr hervorgeht
denn russlandskrieg im Osten unseres
Kontinents ist ja nicht vorbei die
kriegerische Auseinandersetzung im Nahen
Osten auch nicht und in USA stehen im
kommenden Jahr Präsidentschaftswahlen an
möglicherweise mit weitreichenden
Konsequenzen auch für uns hier in
Europa kurz vor Weihnachten haben wir
uns in der Europäischen Union nach 7
Jahren des Stillstands auf eine
tiefgreifende Reform des europäischen
Asylsystems
geeinigt künftig könen wir die
Außengrenzen Europas besser
kontrollieren und auch an den Grenzen zu
unseren Nachbarländern hat die
Bundespolizei ihre Kontrollen verstärkt
das wirkt schon in den vergangenen
Wochen ist die Zahl derer die über diese
Grenzen kommen spürbar
gesunken stark macht uns auch unsere
Demokratie es ist noch gar nicht allzu
lange her da haben mutige Frauen und
Männer auch hier in Deutschland für
freie Wahlen gekämpft vor 35 Jahren war
das als in der DDR die friedliche
Revolution
begann mitzureden und mitzuentscheiden
das ist ein kostbares Gut Diskussionen
über den richtigen Weg gehören dazu das
Ringen um fair Kompromisse
ebenfalls auch wenn ich auf manche laute
Debatte in den vergangenen Wochen und
Monaten durchaus hätte verzichten können
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch ganz ohne
Diskussion über den richtigen Weg
funktioniert Demokratie nicht nicht wird
besser wenn wir nur übereinander reden
anstatt
miteinander stark macht uns unsere
Bereitschaft zum Kompromiss und unser
Einsatz fürüreinander sowie in den
Teilen Deutschlands die in diesen Tagen
unter dem schrecklichen Hochwasser und
seinen Folgen leiden ich denke an alle
Betroffenen denen wir selbstverständlich
helfen und die wir in diesen schweren
Stunden nicht alleine lassen und ich
danke all denen Frauen und Männern von
der Feuerwehr und Bundeswehr vom THW den
Rettungsdiensten und den vielen
freiwilligen H und Helfern die mit
ganzer Kraft gegen das Hochwasser
kämpfen herzlichen Dank an sie alle für
ihren
Einsatz Liebe Mitbürgerin und Mitbürger
uns macht auch die Einsicht stark dass
jede und jeder gebraucht wird in unserem
Land die spitzenforscherin genauso wie
der Altenpfleger die polizisen genauso
wie der Paketbote die Rentnerin genauso
wie der junge
Auszubildende wenn wir uns das klar
machen wenn wir uns gegenseitig mit
diesem Respekt begegnen dann brauchen
wir keine Angst zu haben vor der Zukunft
dann kann das Jahr 2024 ein gutes Jahr
werden für unser Land auch wenn manches
anders kommt als wir uns das heute am
Vorabend dieses neuen Jahres
vorstellen Ihnen und Ihren Liebsten
wünsche ich von ganzem Herzen ein
gesundes ein friedvolles und ein frohes
neues
[Musik]
Jahr